anne frank her family and four others
lived in secret during the holocaust for
more than two years tucked away behind a
false bookcase in a building in the
dutch city of amsterdam frank wrote
about her experiences in her diary an
account that became one of the most read
books in the world but in 1944 they were
discovered and the following year she
died in a nazi concentration camp in the
decades since the mystery of who
betrayed the franks leading to a raid on
their secret annex has remained unsolved
on sunday 60 minutes john wertheim sits
down with an investigator whose team is
using modern techniques to try to answer
that question
before long suspects emerge dozens of
them like villain van marin an employee
in the warehouse where the franks were
hiding whom the dutch police had
interviewed in their investigations he
was prime suspect number one after the
war he's working downstairs in the
warehouse he was very shifty suspicious
actually a thief so he's a shifty
suspicious thief
and yet you eliminated him as a suspect
not a betrayer though he was not
anti-semitic
he had incentive
not to betray them because if he did
he would have lost his job the business
would have been closed what specifically
are you looking for when you're
considering suspects we're looking at
did they have the knowledge we look at
their motive you know what would the
motive be were they anti-semitic um were
they trying to do this for money and
then opportunity were they even in town
knowledge mode of opportunity that's i'm
guessing what you're using when you're
infiltrating drug cartels i mean this is
standard fbi it's standard law
enforcement technique
it's an intriguing mystery wow i don't
know it's never been answered i think
we've probably all read diary of a name
yeah her book i read it as a little girl
and i was deeply affected by it because
you keep thinking about what her life
must have been like what her family must
have been like and how afraid they must
have been in two years think about that
that's that's how long they were in
hiding that's the entire pandemic you're
behind a false wall and the tragedy of
the anne frank story is that they were
given up and died just before the war
was over and the camps were limited
liberals unbelievable story uh i'm
looking forward to seeing that you can
watch it
this sunday on 60 minutes